foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
oh happy New Year
wow hey hey happy New Year you're an
elephant no it's the um
noisemaker you know those things that go
yeah yeah yeah yeah not the elephant
dude yeah so [ __ ] it's the new yeah
yeah
I can't I mean I don't have a [ __ ]
you're doing the sound of an elephant
not the thing
oh
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so yeah
so bad making it about the Bing Bong no
it's good this is the year of the Bing
Bong everybody knows that you're the
Bing Bong this is the year of the Bingo
what is the Bing Bong well the the Bing
Bong is uh I just say this a lot
okay so it doesn't really have any sort
of really core deep meaning no it does
because if other people do it too then
we're all doing living the year the Year
of the Bing Bong it's a great title yeah
already starting a year off with a blast
happy New Year everybody Lifeline 2023
there will not be another year that goes
by where Lifeline hasn't been a show all
year round last year we started and this
year is what I like to call season two
ah
wow
most annoying guy in the world that like
that bit as a guy on stage
[Music]
that's what makes me sad
it's like filled with emotion yeah yeah
it is dude why is that
uh because you think about time yep it
makes you think about time no such thing
as time baby
I mean so Versace no such thing as time
baby there is though right you know why
boy that was just time that went by yeah
yeah yeah well look
certain brains like mine
uh are very expansive and can can can
contain very expansive ideas
uh little ones like yours can't do that
no no I have a big brain okay my I have
a big big big big big brain okay
um
but I will say
we got to like I wore this because it's
um what do you call it
um merch but the January 1st start off
the year with the spin move mentality
that's what we do on New Year's
resolution you can get uh merch
lifelinemirch.com uh you can if you have
a question or want to submit a video and
you need advices go to watch
lifeline.com and if you want those
one-on-one sessions advice sessions with
Matt then you go to mattdelia.com and
it's great
um I am going to be in San Diego coming
up in a week
in a week uh this weekend this next
weekend I'm gonna be in San Diego uh
Brea California we got stuff popping off
in Brea California Portland
Oregon Seattle Washington Lakeland
Daytona and Jacksonville I'm doing a
Florida run he's doing a Florida run
he's doing a Florida run
um San Antonio Sugarland is doing a
Texas run
Texas wow New Orleans you know that
because that's how I say it because
that's how they say it so
Providence Rhode Island New York City uh
Chicago Kansas City I'm gonna do them
all Springfield Missouri Tulsa
Tulsa uh [ __ ] Oklahoma I know uh
Austin Texas Midland Texas Minneapolis
Minnesota Columbus Cincinnati Ohio Boise
chrisley.com get your tickets it's
selling out dude the dumb Push Me Tour
[ __ ]
oh
elephant no it's a a noise maker dude
which is the word I was looking for yeah
how how terrible is something called the
noise maker yeah it's a terrible thing
it's just like it has been invented just
to make noise that's it created the
[ __ ] most annoying pathetic oh piece
of [ __ ] a noise maker killed your
significant other I mean why just being
called a noise maker like give it a name
yeah I understand uh the name is noise
maker I think that's a really great name
because what you see is what you get and
that kind of a thing and I would never
buy a noisemaker and it's very annoying
when people have noisemakers and it's
very annoying when people use
noisemakers which is always on New
Year's Eve don't do that I think
honestly celebrate the New Year in
quietness I have a dream actually okay
of driving to the middle of nowhere with
nobody just myself okay and I don't
think this will ever happen because like
you know I'm a family man and all that
yeah but being in the middle of nowhere
going at 11 o'clock and just waiting and
just just seeing if I can feel the new
year you ever think about that I wonder
if you'd be able to feel they'll
probably be light and all that stuff
going you might hear
you know the uh no I don't think that
that is something what you're like feel
the new year right no I know but I'm
saying it probably you'd probably have
to go to like legitimately miles and
miles and miles away in the middle of
nowhere to not recognize that the new
year has happened because of the lights
and all the fireworks and stuff you'll
be seeing it from afar right no matter
what you think so yeah I think so I bet
those places
many places deep in the desert in
America that are just you couldn't see
yeah a thing right but then it's like
how do you get back and then it's like
you could be stranded you could die okay
don't don't do it I mean no one should
do it but so that's what I'm saying it's
a Dream It's a pipe dream right yeah but
why that doesn't sound enjoyable in any
way because I'm a guy who gets very
anxious I'll tell you that much and I
get very anxious when it comes to the
number one thing and that's change
that's the number one thing on my
anxiety and when the New Year why what
the new year because things are fine as
they are right everything's fine I'm
living I'm healthy I got good stuff who
knows what could happen the next instant
and so the point is change terrifies me
all good so deeper need to talk about it
with my therapist but change it
terrifies me and that's not uncommon
okay so it's uncommon but for me it is
it is uncommon for the way I deal with
it because that will get my heart
palpitating now you know that doesn't
feel good because it accesses my anxiety
and it makes me work overtime my heart
starts beating I get get you know clammy
hands and I get nervous now
we all deal with these things in
different ways but my thing is I don't
want to be a dick to people when I am
feeling anxiety and when I am in the
middle of nowhere when the New Year's
ball drops
I will that is the biggest change all
year round
didn't want to admit it but I don't I
don't even understand what I didn't want
to admit it what did you just admit
you go into the middle of the desert
would would erase that anxiety you're
saying because I wouldn't know when the
ball drops okay right so I wouldn't know
when to be anxious so therefore it would
be minimized okay dude I'm a doctor in a
way right not in the traditional sense
but no doctor would recommend anything
you drive out to the middle of the
desert take two of them call me in the
morning
um yeah dude it's uh it's tough man deal
with a lot of anxiety all good man but
uh you know what I mean I'm off my uh
I'm off my meds well not not off my I
don't go off your mouth not off my meds
I don't take um zany
and I do take uh uh
that's [ __ ] made it up
yes starting this year rip roaring
admitting to everything calipram yeah
that's what it's called really yeah you
didn't make that up nope there's
Citalopram and Citalopram which is very
scary so confusing and I also had s at
telegram set teleframe yeah and then it
I think the doctor wrote it wrong once
and then I started taking Citalopram and
it's basically the same but I switched
my medications without even knowing it
because my doctor has messy handwriting
oh well you know what hey doctors yeah
no don't have handwriting anymore that's
true that's true and I don't have it
also we have computers also don't have a
drug called Citalopram and acetylafram
yeah this is
[Laughter]
so yeah uh Happy New Year everybody
what'd you do for New Year's can't hear
you but you can say it out loud and um
you know you know it was good this is
New Year 2023 hopefully this is a great
year hopefully it's better than last
year you know we had some rough Years
starting with covet and uh now we're off
we're off and running on 2023. do you
have any New Year's resolutions
uh
yes you do yeah okay
um wanna talk about it or no sure okay
uh my main one is to be more pimp and
Pimpin than I've ever been okay and how
do you do that
just like really every night think about
the previous day and what I could have
done to have been even more pimpin
pimpin okay then look at the days the
day ahead uh like the schedule what's on
my docket what's on the schedule a
calendar and then I say okay how can I
be the most amount of and each of these
moments right yeah exactly yeah at night
tomorrow yeah
okay so that actually could have been
more than that
tomorrow from three to four I'm doing
nine it's not very pimpin pimpin but you
can make it as an idea I could change
that I wake up tomorrow plan ahead the
pimp and pimpiness and reflect on the
Pimpin pimpiness wow and see if it was
maximized or if the worst Pastor plan
ahead on the Pimpin pimpiness maximize
yo pimpiness yeah
um
just trying to do you know God's work oh
that's that's what God's work is
um well I my New Year's resolution yeah
what is it be ripped as [ __ ] be ripped
as [ __ ] yeah be rip the [ __ ] in a cool
dad you know just be you're gonna get
ripped I I'm not gonna I don't here's
the deal man I don't really think that
uh I subscribe to New Year's resolutions
yeah me neither yeah because really
I'm not gonna one A new year is Not
Gonna Change me change is something
that's inevitable now I told you to make
me anxious but you need to be growing
with the change and uh so that should be
happening every week right or every day
every second generally they're they're
well-meaning all of them what is people
want to lose weight people want to get
oh yeah this or that people want to be
nicer to whatever the [ __ ] people want
to be more focused these are all good
things but
it should have nothing to do with the
year
you should have to do with oh I realized
I want to do this yeah it's better for
me yeah I want to start doing it like if
you have a New Year's resolution and you
'd figure it out at in December 5th and
you're like oh I gotta be nicer to
people right don't you're just gonna be
a dick for 25 days exactly yeah yeah
right to start now I'll work on
apologizing and holding doors open in a
few weeks dude let me get out my stuff
let me get out my dickness now yeah
thickness so um yeah and uh but I don't
I don't really have one wow I keep I
mean
yeah no and uh so yeah if you have a New
Year's resolution stick with it but do
it honestly man you should have had it
already just let's all work on trying to
be better people this year let's all
work on trying to be nice to each other
let's all work on trying to be positive
you know not assume the worst of people
and also assume the worst period end of
yourself it's a deeper but uh you know
you got it going right
yeah hey everybody listen you got it
going on yeah and all you need to do is
dig down deep inside and realize you got
it going on okay cool okay all right
well great so everybody's got it going
on yeah they just need to be reminded of
that fact yeah so sometimes you can
remind yourself and just say you know
what Paul whoever you are right look in
the mirror Rita
I mean in the mirror hi Rita I'm on
that's like I'm Rita I know hi Rita
you got it going on that would be really
if she said that yep and then she knows
she's got it going on she moves forward
with her life not necessarily that easy
but you're talking about
self-affirmation ideally this is the
ideal the ultimate ideal you know
obviously we hit bumps along the way but
they're saying if you force yourself to
smile more you'll actually be happier
that's what they say I've heard that
yeah yeah because your Bot you can trick
your brain reverse engineer yeah it
doesn't work no no do that all day every
day and you will be so happy for the
rest of your life yeah ah I know and my
magic will hurt yeah that's true but
yeah but I'll be happy as [ __ ] with
hearty cheeks hurting cheeks
hurty cheeks all right well uh look man
we're gonna get into it I know we'll
banter in between but uh we will have a
we will have a good time and uh let's
get into the first one so here we go my
babies
and I am 25 years old and I need some
brotherly advice lives in a Starbucks my
brother is almost 30 and he still asked
me for financial help
and my parents have told me no do not
help him at all he has to learn how to
be responsible
but I have a hard time saying no of
course because
he lives in a really rough part of town
his friends are not the most reliable
people and he works in a really rough
part of town as a bartender and he comes
home at like 4 a.m and that is when
there's some there's a rough crowd where
he is yeah we know about that so he'll
call me asking for Uber rides or gas
money or money here and there for help
and I am very concerned for his life all
the time just because he's had a really
colorful drug history and he's died
twice and came back oh [ __ ] I mean you
know like at this point I'm like if
anything I can do to help him survive
the night I would like to do that but I
also want him to learn
how to be responsible like he's almost
30. uh but I think y'all could have some
pretty good advice on this uh thank you
all love y'all damn they're all damn
yeah that's rough I mean to drop that in
the like we I was like okay okay and
then she said he died twice and it's
just like oh God that's very serious wow
dying is serious yeah the most serious
thing is dying yes dying generally yeah
right but also dying the only thing
above that that's more serious is is uh
NCIS New Orleans have you seen that very
serious yeah I mean all the time there's
literally no humor you're right oh oh I
see yeah yeah yeah and she has New
Orleans Scott Bakula okay oh Scott
Bakula Scott Bakula Lucas Black and then
Lucas Black huh yeah who's the woman and
there's two women and they're both women
that I've one of them I've seen before
and then there's also another guy named
uh oh dude go to the cast actually
before we get to this woman
oh wow just look at the cat okay go to
the cat go go down okay Daryl Mitchell
you see that guy right there I do okay
that guy's name on the credits yeah on
the credits is Daryl chill Mitchell like
in quotes that's what it is on the NCIS
thing how cool is that very cool any ax
in a wheelchair and he is in a
wheelchair I didn't know that the guy's
been in so much [ __ ] dude what a badass
and it's so funny that his name is
chilling he's always sitting down though
that's a chill yeah but uh but yeah so
those are the people in it and so CCH
Pounder Jesus his name
oh dude the name who where oh it is wow
dude that's so bad dude how about Dwayne
Pride Dwayne Cassius pride is his name
and they call him King
many names all the [ __ ] Scott pacular
you're talking about yeah yeah all right
let's not get too far into the answer I
think we should have a Pockets solely on
ncis's and how rich Mark Harmon must be
because he's a producer forget it uh but
yeah anyway uh there's nothing more
serious than that except for maybe death
is up there I think death is number two
NCIS Nola is number one so this woman is
a has a very serious question and also
I you know I hate to say it but why
don't you go ahead and then I can
okay uh yeah I'm just gonna straight up
like the bottom line is that if that was
you if the brother in that situation was
you yeah I would always give you the
money then when you asked for it no
matter how many times people told me not
to I would I would really probably not
as long as I had the money I would
probably not be able to not
um do that so at what I understand that
completely because I feel the same way
but at what point is she enabling his
behavior
because there does become a point if it
look it sounds like he's got a drug
problem if he died twice and has a
colorful drug history right so I got the
impression that he did do drugs oh okay
all right and now he's asking for money
for like uber rides okay well that's
different that's what I'm saying if
somebody's trying to get their [ __ ]
together yeah just because they're not
like totally high functioning adults yet
if he's clean yeah that's the big caveat
yeah if he's that's good if he's clean
you you should keep helping him it may
be tough but also he has a job right she
says he gets off work at 4am yeah so
he's obviously getting some sort of
income bartender you could be making
very little money you could be but you
could also be making you could also be
pocketing a lot of cash and getting
drugs so I'm saying like find out where
he's spending his money I think if this
is something that's been like a problem
you gotta definitely
get access to how he's spending his
money you know if you're if you're
giving them money I think it's fair
enough to be like how are you spending
this money yeah totally yeah so I think
that that's very important because you
could find out something crazy like
maybe he's got a gambling problem or
some [ __ ] I don't know this guy but but
um
you know he lives in a rough area town
for now but if he's got a job and he's
working money make sure also if you have
access to how he's spending the money
you could help him try and save [ __ ]
usually you've got a great hat on your
shoulders yeah
um but yeah that's a tough spot to be in
I don't know if I could ever stop giving
you money if you needed it like I don't
feel I don't think so yeah even if I
really thought you were using it on
drugs I'd be like
it opens a question of like what do you
do if you think you're enabling because
like some people literally are just like
a suck for their family and friends and
like your behavior just ruins people's
lives and and you've got you know you
suffer from this addiction or whatever
it is and uh those people unfortunately
some of those people need to be cut off
completely to even learn their lesson or
to even hit a bottom
but yeah it's tough man you're in a
tough position because obviously you
know I mean it sounds like you have a
family that loves each other and this
guy just you know the teaching people a
lesson thing has always been hard for me
I don't know it's like I almost I don't
believe in that yeah people learn their
own lessons yeah you don't you don't you
don't have the power to teach people a
lesson no you don't unless they're a
child and you are it's parent that's a
pretty good point actually I just I I
understand the mentality behind it I
don't know if that's a thing though yeah
like I don't know if I believe in that
as an actual thing well I guess less
than that and more you're going you know
the guy's not going to be able to learn
a lesson unless he
can access the point of his lowest so he
can be forced to learn it I mean it's
not really like you're teaching them a
lesson right but like you're not
enabling them anymore and I'm not saying
this is what you're going through
because he sounds like he's clean now
but you know yeah that that ultimately
that's the end that's the end of the
advice relief the question for us from
us is is he still using or is he sober
now if he's sober now keep giving him
[ __ ] gas money the guy's trying to
find hard if he's not sober then
also it's [ __ ] hard dude to like to
get out of this hole and get out of
people you know getting a job is [ __ ]
hard getting back on your feet is hard
getting on your feet is hard it's all
[ __ ] hard man so I think that if you
have the stuff to give and it's family
then you give it I I think that that's
great you're being you you seem like
it's it's great to you know sorry about
the situation but you know it's nice to
start the year off with something very
very touching that you you obviously
have a big heart and for that I say
[Music]
absolutely now what was the thing I said
it's the year of the what Bing Bong oh
yes see I already forgot but remind me
okay yeah so to you stop moving you
young lady I say
it's the year of the bing bong and
that's what it's going to be I don't
think I like that honestly oh too
[ __ ] bad okay I I the pimp and Pippin
thing is fine I like that oh now you
like it but the Bing Bong thing yeah the
Pippa Pippa thing grew on me okay okay
maybe in the Bing Bong well uh uh what
about what about the
you know I like I've always like pulled
well
yeah but
it's kind of it's all right okay all
right you know losing your mind
uh yeah so I don't know I feel yeah
that's what that's our advice oh yeah
it's easy clean then keep helping if
he's not
maybe stop helping yeah great let's go
another one
so serious Matt Chris oh my God I got a
problem man uh in the last week I'll be
in the living room or the kitchen I hear
my bed squeaking like there's some
[ __ ] going on in there I'm not in
there so I go to investigate come to
find out there is [ __ ] going on Wow
don't be [ __ ] my pillow this guy's
still so I'm curious you know is he mad
at me
at a lover yeah what man I don't know if
y'all are dog experts but I'm desperate
for answers man thank you guys for all
the free content love y'all oh thanks
buddy appreciate you I got some Steely
blue eyes huh
he's an alluring kind of character yeah
he is uh so your dog's [ __ ] your
rapidly [ __ ] your pillow oh you added
rapidly but yeah he's probably not doing
it when he leaves the room the dog runs
in and [ __ ] his pillow that's a
hilarious dude that is hilarious all I
would say to you is get that on video
and go viral dude because other than
that I don't know if there's much you
can do besides is oh yeah that's right
close your door
dude if our advice is literally just
[ __ ] door yeah yeah there you go is
it normal that's totally normal we had a
[ __ ]
dog when we were kids it would uh oh
yeah the legs of but particular groups
of people more likely than others what
yeah uh
uh girls like girls I would invite over
when I was like 13 or 14. oh
and Mexican men no yeah dude oh my God
our dog had a kink too from Mexican man
well yeah and [ __ ] young whoa dude
dude when the dog came over I was like
when he leaves when he leaves the dog
from the back of the room
wait a minute I'm not in there I get it
hold up I'm not in there and noise is
coming from there and the duck the duck
yeah the dark
can't stop it can't stop it the dog just
like this with the pillow dude I feel
like uh your dog's trying to assert
dominance
either way in a sneaky way which is the
worst dude close the door close the door
but also you don't you wanna
you don't want to necessarily physically
stop the dog from doing it you want the
dog you want to mentally stop the dog
from doing it you want to use your mind
you want to Professor X this situation
this guy's trying to brute force it
you know he's closing doors and [ __ ] no
you want the dog to understand so when
he does that you [ __ ] his chew toys
don't take his little [ __ ] bone
beanie put it put in your butt dude oh
yeah
his dog would love that bad for him
twice
that would smell like the owner and the
dog would just eat the but it would
probably stop humping the thing and then
would just eat the bone because it had
the owner's [ __ ] away You're creating a
circle of disgustingness though all you
got to do is close the door
also him doing it behind your back I
don't know if it's dominance do you
think it's dominance he's like a
sneakily [ __ ] oh yeah it's just like a
weird unless the dog is really smart and
the dog's like dude dishonor thinks he
is the top dog but really I'm the top
dog when he leaves I'm gonna I'm gonna
bust all over his pillow and he's gonna
have to sleep on it right what if the
dog actually like [ __ ] all over the
pillows yeah you know well unless if
he's not neutered it may be possible oh
yeah I guess I didn't think about that
yeah if he's not neutered neuter your
dog first of all second of all close the
door yeah both of those things at once
yeah so I just so I you know I call in
man I wake up dog jizz is on my cheek
yeah
um yeah bro your dogs your dogs
honestly you're losing this battle Yeah
your dog's quite the character but close
the door yeah but you're losing this
battle and you're gonna lose this battle
and if you close the door I feel like
honestly it's
you're mentally losing the battle you're
physically winning but okay fine you're
just you're basically women because
you're winning because you have thumbs
and your dog doesn't well dude use them
to your Advanced I understand of all
time yeah you want to Professor X's
situation though dude it's much better
because then the dog will behave better
in a real in the whole for everything
well let's well how about this
experiment this way
try closing the door
then take another video and let us know
what happens your pillow began starts
just other stuff then we got a real
problem all right like if he's like oh
well he's going to close the door to the
bathroom he's just scratching on the on
they're not just gonna go like [ __ ]
fill my butthole with toilet paper or
something you know weird but the dog
yeah the scratching on the bedroom door
with his lipstick out just come on man
hit that pillow a good junkie
um all right he's red rocket yeah yeah
lipstick red rocket same thing okay well
lipstick's grosser yeah of course yeah
so I mean red rocket is I mean you know
Red Rock is like more lipstick close
because you put it on your mouth exactly
right but I don't because I'm a guy but
you know yeah you think about it taking
a dog and putting the lipstick all over
the oh my God
where'd you put the lipstick it's under
the dog again uh all right
so my question today is I'm 19 years old
going to college I wasn't currently
going to a party that guy's 19 years old
hiding from Michael Myers
the [ __ ] most chill Halloween the
most Chiller he's 19 yeah but what's the
matter don't think you think he looks
older
he looks 35.
that guy looks like he's got two kids
come on dude bro the guy look at his
face it doesn't look that old dude
in the pool with the handle thing
he gets sidetracked
what is this
pina colada yeah do it just got
sidetracked dude okay
a lot of fun I love it uh I met some
great dudes there all getting a house
next year I mean they're genuinely some
of my best friends even though I've only
known them for a year uh career-wise
though a degree from this school isn't
going to cut it so I need to transfer to
you know a better school
um and I found one that I'm able to get
into I meet the requirements
So the plan is to transfer there my
junior year and uh that's gonna suck so
I'll be leaving all my best friends and
so I just need some advice on how to
make sure I stay steady on that and
myself and Nim don't kind of change my
mind and persuade me to stay because it
would be more fun and easier to stay
with them but I need to go so advice on
that please okay when you're 19 now
doesn't matter at all
have fun don't have fun who the [ __ ]
cares you're 19 nothing matters what
does matter is nihilistic well no what
does matter is your future so if you go
into this better school means a way
better future for you it's a [ __ ]
no-brainer how am I
and the new no matter no number of
[ __ ] kickstands can change your mind
about that [ __ ] there you go you got
your friends you make more friends don't
worry about that you're gonna make
friends wherever you go
so he's basically saying should he go to
this school to and how do I how do I
leave Temptation at the door and
continue with my plans to go to this
school and make sure my friends don't
convince me to stay and let my mind sort
of fall back into this place of I'm
gonna stay at this school because it's
more fun and easier and that's it
Temptation uh you got to get away from
Temptation and you gotta absolutely uh
do the school yeah but you know it's
just like uh give up you know whatever
well you know it's like he's got to give
up that's why it was a micro to the
macro it's like did you just got to give
up on this party last time the guy's
taking the [ __ ] video literally from
a pool he's hiding from his friends
chill you know he's like I gotta hide my
friend from my friends to do this video
they're inside they're doing cake stands
getting sucked off dude hey should I go
to school but I'm having so much fun my
boner just went down you know what I
mean for the first time in a few days
yeah
so I don't know I I uh you the good
thing about friends in college you're
not going to be friends with them for in
three years anyway oh yeah you know you
might be like carry on with them you
might be in a text message group with
them but it's like dude people change
people grow apart your friends are gonna
do it to you so you do it first and look
out for your future before your friends
could look out for theirs yes dude
sometimes it comes comes in clutch
I honestly tuned out a little bit but
that's rude that's probably good advice
that's rude but it's good dude it's good
and uh and I I I hope to figure out your
future dude you're only 19 even though
you're 35 and I feel like you'll you
know by the time you're the age that you
look you'll have everything figured out
oh yeah and you have a bunch of new
friends and you'll be swimmingly in your
career no pun intended because you're in
the pool when you're 35 for real you'll
have a hard time remembering what those
friends even look like
the whole movie the whole movie
don't think
so is that him getting started after he
kills somebody yeah he killed someone
the guy died and then he saw the the
floating device yeah and then he laid it
and then laid in it and it's so hard to
get on you know
how [ __ ] is it trying to get into a
floating device yeah yeah how do you
even do it dude you can't do it and not
be bit no there's no way Jason Momoa do
it be a [ __ ] the only way to do it is
to jump on it from outside the pool but
even still that's [ __ ] you're gonna
hurt your balls dude yeah maybe you run
the risk you run the risk of hurting
your ball so it's like either do you be
[ __ ] or do you run the risk of hurting
your balls what would you pick I'd just
be [ __ ]
who's around don't matter I just be
[ __ ]
yeah I guess choose me but you can't
hurt the balls yeah [ __ ] it can't hurt
the balls dude can't hurt the baby
makers right bro
dude baby makers that's so [ __ ]
stupid
guy looking at him dude grilling all
right cool the bit's done um you keep
going until it you know my question is
to you guys I've been in a relationship
that's getting pretty serious and it's
made my best friend go away uh he
basically called me a simp and a [ __ ]
whoa uh said I don't have time for him
now which makes us sound like we're
married which is ridiculous so uh I
wanted to know it's given me a lot of
anxiety wondering when he's gonna text
or if he's just going away forever or if
it even matters was he really my friend
what should I do thank you guys I mean
the market machines guy dude she's just
not the real thing that is pathetic I
don't know it's so weird bro when the
guys get like that about their friends
who are [ __ ] found happiness with the
partner like dude what kind of [ __ ]
selfish prick is this guy yeah I don't
get dudes that do that [ __ ] neither I
don't get dudes that get their feelings
hurt with like this is the same type of
dude that's like oh man you know you
guys went and and and went to the
baseball game and didn't invite me dude
you don't need to invite everybody to
everywhere I know I've said this before
but like I don't understand dudes that
get their feelings hurt by other dudes
about this kind of stuff yeah it's you
know it's this guy's just living his
life yes he's not doing anything
outwardly to this other buddy it's also
he's living his life and good things are
happening he met someone he loves yeah
it's good this dude if he was a real
friendly be happy he want you know what
he wants he wants to pull you down so he
can be miserable with you he wants to
commiserate with you he wants a
commiserating buddy that's what he wants
well among other things yeah it also
doesn't want his friend to be happier
than he is but that's what I'm saying
that's [ __ ] because he's then he
would be miserable and then he could be
miserable with me yeah I don't like that
[ __ ] if you get a girl or get a boy or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and then that
their friends are like you don't hang
out anymore that's what life is supposed
to be dude I'm not gonna make a baby
with you bro yeah I'm trying to live my
life
I'm trying to have a family
adopt a kid with me then dude
yeah I mean I it's pretty mind-boggling
when when people get like this it's like
well we're just friends this is my
potential life partner yup like what are
you talking about I know what you do
next time you see the dude you go like
this
oh what are you backing away for we're
in a relationship and the guy says no
we're not and he says then why are you
upset I'm in one dude yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
you know what I mean I kiss people I'm
in a relationship with bro yeah yeah
yeah I mean
you could you could just text him and be
like dude are you really doing this like
what is wrong with you or as you
suggested just [ __ ] live with it Let
It Go who cares yes this sucks dude yeah
sorry I know it does suck and you know
you got to figure out yourself but let's
let's put it this way most relationships
end so yeah your buddy's probably right
about like you know but still he's you
got to figure that out for yourself I'm
just playing devil's advocate here
oh yeah remember that movie how could I
forget
oh I'm the devil
oh yeah having sex oh I'm the devil the
devil having sex all right no
hey guys I have a quick question today
on whether or not I should drop this
friend she's been my oldest friend since
elementary school but recently I've been
feeling like she doesn't talk to me
about anything
positive it's always about her negative
relationships or when she's going
through breakups
um she'll go months on end without
talking to me when she's in a happy
relationship and she never asks me how
I'm doing so I feel like I don't want
her kind of really like energy in my
life anymore
I don't know if that's a petty reason to
stop being friends with somebody like
talk about me you never ask me how I'm
doing I don't know if that's Petty
enough to be like I don't want to be
friends with you anymore but I just feel
like she never wants to see me be
successful
um she only wants to talk about herself
so should I drop her how do I do that
it's it's hard because I still love her
and we have a lot of history together
um
it's been hard trying to figure it out
so I appreciate it thank you so what's
the difference between this one news
flash not all of your friends want you
to be happy
they want you to be like them I'll do
you one more but the different you ask
the question the difference between
these two videos is the one that wasn't
like [ __ ] you I'm out of this friendship
she was just in this instance she's her
friend is like complaining to her like
why don't we ever talk about me or
whatever the [ __ ] okay she's not like
I'm out of here I'm not your friend
anymore okay this girl's wondering if
she should be the one that just
go son her friend oh so it's like the
opposite yeah the inverse yeah uh I you
know I also think I'm gonna do one more
you not all your friends want what's
best for you
honestly most of your friends are
probably secretly your enemy yes
dude you know how close an enemy is to a
friend
one move away
one move
you learn somebody's your enemy
real quick dude and they're doing you a
favor
so maybe this is the thing man people
don't want you to be happy friends
people don't want to be happy enemies
definitely don't want to be happy
friends
probably are your enemy so they
definitely don't want you to be happy
there's a there's a thing though friend
the when when you realize who your
friends really are are times like this
there are friends who will be happy for
you because you found someone and then
it's like oh [ __ ] yeah Mike is in such a
good relationship he was bumming for so
long but I'm so happy to see him and
have having a good time with this new
girl uh then there's the version of the
friend that's like
[ __ ] Mike's always hanging out with his
chick dude like what do you mean dude
yeah he is of course he is what the [ __ ]
I was gonna do hang out with your
[ __ ] smelly ass I think what you
should do is honestly and I've thought
about this before having zero friends
and every year at the end of the year
you pay people in your life a nominal
fee this way technically you can say
that you're they're working for you and
whenever they do [ __ ] like this you go
you don't get paid this year but you
don't have friends
I'm giving everyone a 20 I know at the
end of next year 2023 I'm starting it
with this year it's January 1. I'm
paying everyone I know that's even close
to like kind of a friend they're all
getting well maybe a 10 or if there's
many people but man and then enough it's
not enough to make a difference you know
what I mean you're gonna make it like
four or five hundred dollars no but no
why because otherwise what's 10 bucks it
gives a [ __ ] but I know but then
technically they're an employee of mine
is what I'm saying and then if they
backstab me or if they start to wish me
harm or not be hold their their weight I
don't pay them that year right and then
they go like this but and I say we're
not friends you just don't work for me
anymore yeah right right that's awesome
dude [ __ ] yeah we figure [ __ ] out a lot
of like yeah I don't know I gotta go to
the bank between Christmas and New
Year's and get a bunch of Tenors
Tenors you know so English and then just
here you go here you go to people that I
talk to me anyone that I talk to like
more than five times that year otherwise
you don't get paid they're not a friend
or anything but like you know okay it
sounds like it sounds complicated it is
complicated but your heart feels way
better I don't know and it's about
business right it's about business okay
okay I think that's great I wish
somebody I gotta do you know I must if
you're somebody who's really rich to do
that here's the thing
[ __ ] anyone who says they're a friend
and then tries to tell you you don't
spend enough time with them because
you're always with your partner who you
love and want to share your life with
okay only friends who are happy for you
this is this that's kid [ __ ] we're
adults now yep okay okay good we figured
it out next one
I've got a question regarding a mate of
mine and my friend group who has a
problem with drinking
um can't seem to go out without having
getting to the point where it's really
like does it black out drunk oh god
making mistakes
is for example vomiting all over my
girlfriend's dinner counter oh God and
just at a party so embarrassing himself
but also embarrassing us but mainly
himself and he'll get emotional leave
the party early just ruins his time and
obviously
me and my friend group want him to come
out but we also don't want to have the
burden of looking after someone who
looks to us
for him for us to look after him while
he's out which we shouldn't have to yeah
but it seems like we have to for him to
actually have a good night and also for
us to not have to look after
someone like that
um because yeah we want him to come out
and have a good time but it's too
difficult at times yeah so my question
is how do you help someone like that
you know have a good time drink the
right amount with actually knowing the
limit without going overboard
um yeah
love you both love the podcast everyone
um I have a friend like this and I kind
of stopped hanging out with you he can't
he can't he don't he doesn't know the
limit yeah if he does he doesn't and
keep it in mind it sucks but it's a
disease and this is how it affects you
you know but I think no I see I mean if
he's as good a friend as this guy says
he is he should talk to him about it
yeah open he is to actually trying to
change and if he gets really defensive
then it's like well I don't know if we
can go out with you anymore man yeah
[ __ ] nuisance and we gotta babysit
you yeah but if he's like oh no it's
kind of a problem isn't it and then you
go with them and help them yeah you know
but the bottom line is one or the other
though he shouldn't be going out with
you anymore
yeah well if he takes the help then he
won't be doing that either I have a
buddy that I've talked to about it a
little bit not too much you know but
like he has a drinking problem and we
just kind of stopped hanging out uh as
much as we used to because it just is
like it's just too hard it's just too
you know
he'll like corner you and [ __ ]
for 10 minutes and talk about something
you know and you're just like oh well
it's not that bad not like what he's
doing no no no no no this guy's got a
light problem but I mean if you have a
[ __ ] big problem you know I don't
know it sucks too because the behavior
you learn is something you do over and
over again and then it's a cycle and
it's like not only are you addicted to
the actual substance but you're addicted
to the actual uh motion and idea of
going to the bar and ordering a drink
you know you need to unlearn that
behavior you know it's it's a it's a
tough uh it's a tough spot to be in but
uh yeah it sounds like this guy's really
conflicted I think that you gotta I mean
just
you got to say look dude yeah exactly
what Matt says yeah we can't invite you
out anymore we got to take care of you
it's not fun for us we don't want to do
it you know and I'm sorry to say it I'm
here to help you if you want but if not
we're just gonna we gotta go because we
can get crunk without Pat you know
throwing up all over my girlfriend's
table
but you you're the guy who throws who up
Chuck's on the island you can't seem to
do that okay yeah so yeah
yeah I don't know man it's a tough one
addiction is real it's hard to make
jokes about it because uh you know I
know a lot of people this is not that
funny and I also have it so uh but it's
uh I feel for your friend yeah and so do
you and that's totally normal but you
know you gotta [ __ ] give them the
Straight Talk
give them a chance to change at least
all right
what's going on Matt and Chris Justin
versus Matt
I don't know which is better that that's
my question
which what what should I say first no
but my question is
because I'm 25. and I work as a plumber
and I'm a third year which means I'm one
year away from getting my license to the
state and I get a big pay increase oh
yeah right but I had this predicament in
my head I started thinking about I'm
like is this really what I want to be
doing you know because I had human [ __ ]
on my clothes and hands yeah like is
this really what I want to what I want
to be doing yeah I can't speak
and it got me to thinking I'm like I
don't know what my dream job would be if
I could choose one
and I just felt kind of lost and I guess
I'd never really thought about that it's
a deeper but I was just wondering how to
go about combating the fact that I don't
know what to do with my life and I feel
kind of lost and uh I guess that's it
all right thanks wow imagine not knowing
what you want to do for the rest of your
life while also getting human [ __ ] all
over you here's the thing
here's the thing it we have all been
lied to since we were kids here we go
we are told
follow your passion
[ __ ] do you know how few people
have a passion yeah some people don't
even have people feel like they're
lacking because most people don't have a
passion they have what is called a job
right because they don't have this inner
deeper drive to do something extremely
specific it's just like they want to
[ __ ] make enough money to have
sometimes have a family sometimes just
support themselves whatever everybody
wants to do their own thing but like the
the LIE is that you're expected to have
a passion that is false it makes people
it makes people feel like this guy
where it's like oh well I don't know
what my passion is I don't know dude
that's [ __ ] fine do something that
you're really good at make a lot of
money at it and wait to see what your
[ __ ] passion is make a lot of money
being a plumber and then maybe when
you're 40 you'll realize oh you know
what I really [ __ ] love uh
fishing by then you'll have a [ __ ]
enough money to buy yourself a sick boat
sick fishing rods and you'll have a
[ __ ] life where you're not only
making money at your job the thing that
you're very good at which also makes you
feel good and reinforces all that [ __ ]
but you also have now have your passion
wow that's good rush to be have a
passion yeah don't rush your passion
don't rush to figure out your past
you're only going to [ __ ] it up and
don't feel like you need to have one you
don't do whatever you're good at until
you know your passion it's perfectly
fine to just have a job and work that
job and work to live and then in the
fourth year start making a lot of money
and then you know this whole what's my
passion you'll figure it out and if you
don't it's also okay yeah right yeah
especially if you could do something
like go to trade school or become a
plumber it's a steady [ __ ] income you
can't make a [ __ ] ton of money and trade
schools are lacking right now dude go
[ __ ] dude make bank at some in some
union job like that and do that for
years and years and then a passion will
come to you and when it does you'll have
like [ __ ] 400 000 in the bank or
whatever the [ __ ] you know that's a lot
but yeah maybe if you're anything like
me you will you know I I don't you don't
do a trade school I'm a [ __ ] plumber
you are
I do HVAC stuff no and I make 400 000 a
year okay I think maybe you don't do any
of those things but uh okay yeah I feel
like uh you're right about that people
say that's like that whole you can do
whatever you put your mind to I don't
like any of that [ __ ] I can't yeah I
don't like any of that [ __ ] any of that
any of that those posters you can buy
with like a whale tail on it that's like
perseverance get the [ __ ] out here with
that [ __ ] go to work get [ __ ] on you
legitim literally get [ __ ] on you and
then buy a boat when you're 40. yeah
that's what that poster should say yeah
get [ __ ] on buy a boat when you're 40.
yeah
yeah and have it bald eagle just like
yeah totally unrelated image yeah yeah
there you go yeah there was a store in
the mall called Reflections that would
have that it was called Reflections and
that they would all sell those posters I
wonder if those [ __ ] things are still
in business not because of the internet
I bet they're like 450 per now those
posters what were they
uh
uh what do you mean
you said they sold posters right yeah
but do they have them anymore
motivational posts yeah the motivational
I bet those are expensive now is what
I'm saying yeah why not the OG ones
because everything like toys you just
make one though oh you think yeah
they're newly printed then they're look
watch The Talk look at these yep
Excellence with the fish jumping what is
it called well the fish didn't even do
that you know that's such Photoshop
we'll just say excellence and then
what's the thing that it says under it
see now I should go back you should go
back right because I said it and he went
too forward it said it what does it say
yeah read it
just say it it says the will to win the
desire to succeed the urge to reach your
full potential these are all the keys
that will unlock the deer the door
a personal Excellence oh it's a no [ __ ]
bomb
that is so
look how long it is wow what's this one
say the glacier with the [ __ ] more
Glacier under it you know always a
glacier well make it bigger
oh wow go to make it bigger make them HD
dude ah make it bigger
pinch it you know pinch it there we go
what does it say 10 iconic motivational
posters it says teamwork is the ability
to work together toward a common Vision
the ability to direct individual
accomplishment toward organizational
objectives I mean it is the full wait oh
sorry it is the fuel that allows common
people to attain uncommon results wow
and then guys are just in a [ __ ]
canoe that is just you know not what do
you call those
ah [ __ ] guys are just [ __ ] 10
dudes in a canoe just doing teamwork
well they needed an image to support
what they were saying uh if I had that
if I saw that poster and I and I did the
rowing I would Row the other way I'd get
so pissed off and I'd be like this is
nothing what's this one above and beyond
look at this [ __ ]
I wanted
when a team of dedicated individuals
makes a commitment to act as one the
sky's the limit unreal that's the same
as the last one they're all the same
dude you buy this [ __ ] for what walk
walked with the Penguins on the beach
dude Penguins don't even go there walk
to talk take the initiative and lead the
way you can make the difference [ __ ]
that's such a [ __ ] dude that's
something that like oh look at this some
people dream of success While others
wake up and work hard at it and it's a
golf course that's so funny to think of
working hard at success
like you know Russians make this yeah
and then sell it they they [ __ ] uh
whoa Farm it out look at this guys you
guys got the backwards way of life we
could have rope in a white a bicycle up
a rope make it happen there is no
challenge too great for those who have
the will and heart to make it happen I
mean is already in it that is just a
fact yeah there is no challenge too
great for those who have the will and
heart to make it happen what is making
it happen dude ah
and then a picture of a guy climbing a
rope also holding on to a bicycle dude
nothing has been more Swedish than this
whole thing what is his what is the
activity dude that is unbelief youth
euthanism enthusiasm
euthanasia euthanasia it is okay to want
to kill yourself
if you are feeling pain Dr Kevorkian
enthusiasm passion creates energy it
strike out with joy whoa what the [ __ ]
the choice of words strike out with joy
and exhilaration and others are sure to
join you how annoying is somebody who
believes that I mean of course you
understand
customer service is this a joke no see
here's the thing they're all [ __ ]
capitalist things underneath this one's
just naked dude just like admitting what
it is yeah yeah what does it say this I
mean Marco read that
the Sea of change can pull customers in
many directions it is our responsibility
to light the way and take care of them
before the competition this is
definitely like when they already sold
and it exhausted the fan base and was
like they sold a bunch of the real ones
and they were like some guy was just
like customer service
and they're like what are we getting
[ __ ] we can do with customers we go to
see a change okay let me go for business
let's try it let's run it we'll do what
we'll run it up mock it up
commitment extraordinary energy
concentrated power and sheer will this
is the potent mix required to break
barriers and reach the Pinnacle of
success the whole recipe of these things
sucks balls dude it's just a vague image
and then a word with like kind of the
definition of that word underneath dude
collaborate collaborate to stand apart
from the competition you must first
stand together as a team and then just a
bunch of trees trees together dude the
[ __ ] Gall dude also they didn't go
out and take these pictures they're all
stock images yeah wow this is before the
internet this [ __ ] popped off dude yeah
people like in like Altadena like like
hung these up in there in their [ __ ]
dentist office you know definitely how
funny is summer school classroom yeah
dude a dentist s.a.t class in a church
oh yeah dude in the back building of a
church you have one of these yeah just
commitment yeah what about my New Year's
resolution is commitment mine is success
and mine is customer service minus
customer service and teamwork and
teamwork yeah
um all right well we're [ __ ] done you
guys look I'm gonna be in San Diego I'll
see you next weekend San Diego I'll see
you next weekend see you guys see you
next week Seattle I'll see you the next
one Portland gonna see the next one
um and uh
California forgot about that when I'm
doing the club there Lakeland
Jacksonville Daytona San Antonio
Sugarland Texas you know a bunch of them
Columbus Ohio Midland Texas Austin Texas
Tulsa Kansas City Chicago New York
Providence christalia.com get your
tickets do you want uh one and one uh
one-on-one advice sessions With Me Yours
Truly Natalia the king of the bing bang
uh go to mattelia.com and book those get
[ __ ] done together if you have a
submission I have a question for us need
advice click the link in the description
below or go to watch lifeline.com and
when you need the merch right here my
brother's wearing uh right now he's
wearing the black hoodie which is Bing
Bong uh go to
lifelinemerch.com also it's cold you
know you need to get your yeah truly yep
it's crazy right yeah it's crazy all
right guys thanks remember it's the year
of the Bing Bong right
okay
so many noises
[Music]
hello